horror movies have to really stick the
landing to last whether that means
coming in with a surprise twist or an
explosive events or even a maddening
cliffhanger the final moments of any
good thriller should bring together all
the jump scares and eerie elements that
have defined the rest of the movie for
these modern flicks the third acts were
so good that they'll easily stand the
test of time let's take a look at the
best horror movie endings of the century
so far and don't be scared but there are
huge spoilers ahead the others this
atmospheric period film follows the
Stewart family a mum under two kids who
start to notice that the house is
haunted there's a couple avoiding the
hallways a ghost boy hiding behind the
curtains and even a freaky blind lady
lurking in the shadows but when Grayson
the children stumble upon a seance in
the Attic they suddenly realize they're
the ones who are deceased her daughter
had been right the whole time about her
mother's maniacal ways as grace
remembers that she murdered her children
and then herself after temporarily going
insane she realizes she stabbed a whole
family to an eternity inside their
creaky mansion it's a gut punch of a
twist and also changes the entire film
when you realize the so-called ghosts
that have been scaring the Stewart's are
actually living people who have moved
into Grace's old home and - they're the
ones being haunted saw these days a
jigsaw is one of the most famous bad
guys to ever torture someone on the big
screen but in 2004 when the first saw
film hit theaters audiences have no idea
what the infamous serial killer actually
looks like in fact for most of the movie
everybody suspected that Seth was a
psycho who abducted and chained up poor
Adam in that bathroom dungeon but after
our hero bashes stepped to bits
he discovers a cassette that reveals the
hospital orderly was just another victim
in jigsaws game and as Adam begins to
process this new bit of info we watch in
horror as a body which has been lying on
the bathroom floor for the whole movie
pulls up off the floor yep this corpse
is the killer himself John Kramer and
when jigsaw walks out of the bathroom he
leaves his latest victim chained to a
pipe parting with his trademark line
with a doozy like that it's no wonder
the movie has spawned a seven sequels
and counting the missed the ending of
the mist is so notorious that it really
needs no introduction but it's still
pretty brilliant and terrible all the
same director Frank Darabont
took a major Liberty with the Stephen
King novel a' to end at the way he dead
but even king ER to compliment the
decision saying i loved it it is the
most shocking ending ever the story
surrounds a supermarket full of people
who have been trapped inside by an
otherworldly mist full of monsters but
they're not exactly safe from harm there
either as the threat outside continues
to dwarf any escape options religious
zealotry begins to overtake as some of
the survivors who threaten to sacrifice
our hero David's son so he and the
others who reject the apocalyptic
overtures make a break for it
after an intense standoff in the
checkout aisle unfortunately they don't
get far before they run out of gas and
faced with certain death by tentacled
terrors David executes his own son and
Friends with a pistol but runs out of
bullets before he can offer himself to
overcome with instant grief he goes into
the mist to accept his fate but finds
that the military has arrived to
eradicate the beasts if only David had
waited just a few seconds his son would
have been okay and we all could have
been spared that emotional devastation
the cabin in the woods possibly the most
meta horror movie ever made the cabin in
the woods follows a bunch of college
students who foolishly spend the weekend
in a creepy forest naturally their
little getaway doesn't go as planned and
they quickly discover they're meant to
be sacrifices in an elaborate ritual to
please some angry ancient entities with
a family of undead rednecks hot on their
trail
the two remaining survivors find
themselves trapped in an underground
bunker surrounded by a bunch of goons
with machine guns without any other
choice our heroes unleash an army of
monsters resulting in one of the wildest
you won't believe until you see it
sequences in horror cinema pretty much
every creature you can imagine shows up
ready to do some damage we've got a
knockoff of penny wise and imitation
pinhead and a master murderous straight
out of The Strangers there's a merman an
enormous bat and one and from the
Unicorn by the time the zombies ghosts
and werewolves are finished slaughtering
everyone in sights
the walls are caked with blood the earth
is doomed and audiences of had a gory
good time
it follows it's hard to come up with a
completely original movie monster
nowadays but it follows combined the
common societal fear of communicable
diseases with traditional terra tribes
to create something entirely new
basically an STD on two legs the titular
it is spread via contact and if you can
track the curse this enigmatic monster
will mercilessly hunt you down and if it
gets you it then goes after the person
who gave you the curse and so on and so
on forever sure the creature moves
pretty slowly but this thing can take
any form necessary to get close enough
to end your life and no matter what's it
never stops following our heroine J does
our best to fly the monster with every
electrical device she can get her hands
on and just to play it safe she gets
down with her friend Paul who then
passes the curse on to a prostitute's
just in case the thing comes back and
that leads us to the eerie image of jay
and paul walking down a neighborhood
street with a man behind them in the
distance maybe it's just a guy walking
or maybe it's the creature that can
never die coming back for round two open
endings are often too frustrating to
withstand but this one fits the theme of
the film like a glove if you catch our
drift get out a modern-day masterpiece
Jordan peels get out almost had a
radically different ending originally
peel planned on having his main
character Chris Washington arrested
after escaping the clutches of the
mind-controlling family fortunately the
writer/director had a change of heart
and crafted a new ending that left
audiences tearing instead of crying to
set the scene chris has just narrowly
avoided the lobotomy to end all the
bottom E's and the drawing his getaway
he dispatches every evil white person
who steps into his path this eventually
ends of Chris standing above his psycho
ex-girlfriend as she's bleeding out on a
country road suddenly flashing lights
appear in the distance and we assume the
worst is about to happen but instead of
the law showing up to cut Chris away who
should step out of the car but Chris's
best friend at TSA officer rod Williams
as rod takes Chris back to safety
everyone in the audience breathes a sigh
of relief knowing full well does kind of
upbeat ending rarely happens in real
life thanks for watching click the loop
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you're loved too
[Music]